This is more perfect. I'm Jad Abumrad today, a story from our producer,
Julia Longoria,
so I've been working on an episode about sex discrimination for like months now.
Yeah, and we're supposed to release it.
Sexual harassment scandals have been golf, Harvey Weinstein,
Senator Al Frank and Louis C k this week after Kevin Spacey date,
we more today, the story we're going to tell is not about sexual harassment,
but I can't think street with all this stuff that's happening.
Look at what's happening with people. Look at a tipping point and all that.
A watershed mold,
thousands posted the claims online using the simple phrase meat too.
This has been happening since the beginning of time,
but now people are finally talking about it and I can't help but think that
we've seen this before where it's outcry for public change and positive ones.
We have a backlash. They claim there's a war on women out there.
No one takes them seriously. If you can't handle some of the basic stuff,
that's become a problem in the workforce today, right?
Like you don't belong in the workforce.
Like we're in our respective corners and men to help us letting out a big
screen. How do people not know? Right?
You get with your ass when things quiet down, call the experts on the line.
[inaudible]
will there be a change?
Hello?
And what kind of change is the kind that will stick?
Today's story is about a time and the not so distant past when there was a
similarly loud rock is division in our country over sexual equality.
And one woman quietly,
strategically laid the foundation for real change.
The honorable,
the chief justice and the associate justices of the Supreme Court of the United
States. Oh, Yay. Yay.
Having business before the honorable,
the Supreme Court of the United States for money to go on air and get married.
[inaudible] card.
[inaudible]
here we are. I'm going to ask you to utterly false question, which is,
where would you like to start?
I if we haven't been doing this for so damn long. Okay,
so let me outline the basic dilemma that's at the heart of the story here.
All right, I'm going to put it to you as a question. Bring it.
If you were to do a control in the constitution,
like how many times do you think the word sex comes up?
Oh, that's interesting.
Six. No guessing. Cause the answer is one.
One time in the 19th amendment,
which grants people the right to vote based on sex. Really? Yes.
That's the only time. That's the only time. Which is crazy because we are none.
Is there a sex word that's not sex? Like gender or something? Something.
Nothing. Is there like ladies in the costume. Women No.
To really. Okay. Constitutionally women have a problem,
which is that basically we're not in the constitution except like in this one
little spot. So when it comes to discriminating against women,
some people have argued that you,
there's nothing in the constitution that says you can't do it.
Certainly the constitution does not require sexual discrimination and
discrimination on the basis of sex constitution doesn't require it.
It simply doesn't forbid it. That's the lead Justice Antonin Scalia.
It doesn't mean nobody ever voted for that.
So where do you get it from? There was nothing that said that. I mean,
not not those words explicitly,
but there was nothing that says you can't discriminate. Uh,
not on the basis of sex. That's legal editor, Christian various.
We had a 14th amendment that told people that we are equal under the law,
that everyone has an equal protection of the laws, but doesn't that say, man,
they never applied the 14th amendment two women,
they didn't apply the 15th that's Martha Griffiths. Congresswoman.
When you think about the history of the 14th amendment as legal editor,
Linda Hirshman says the 14th amendment was passed in the aftermath of the civil
war along with the 13th and the 15th 13th Amendment Abolishing Slavery and 15th
Amendment essentially giving black people really black men the right to vote.
If you understand the 14th amendment to be a part of that trio of amendments,
you're like, oh, okay.
It was meant to bring equality to black people when the 15th amendment had been
written, which had every citizen could vote in the name of heavens.
Why couldn't women vote? Why didn't you,
why did you have to have the 19th amendment? Oh, of course.
The answer was they didn't consider women people, but I was all gone,
but I was old. There was this basic assumption in the law that, you know,
equality for black people is one thing, but men and women,
they're different.
It was the case that the supreme court had never once met a distinction between
men and women. It didn't like Wendy Williams law,
professor emeritus at Georgetown.
What are some greatest hits of the just ridiculous distinction. Okay, here,
here there was a case called Bradwell and it was 1873 or four in that case,
a woman wanted to become a lawyer.
Illinois bar said no, and the justices said that, um,
that that was a perfectly good rule because the justice system could be seen as
not appropriate for women. Now, let's jump clear into the next century here.
1948 in his case it was called guesser versus Cleary that went to the Supreme
Court and the issue was whether women could be bartenders.
The court thought that that was pretty humorous,
that it made sense that women could not be bartenders and less their husbands or
fathers were in charge. Of the bar.
Both those laws,
you know women are not supposed to be at the bar at either bar. Right.
Those two cases represent attitudes almost 80 years apart that women belonged in
the private sphere. That was not only their place,
it was built into their bodies and that was the assumption for a long,
long time,
but just about 67
there are a lot of women in this country who feel like they're being pushed
around.
Thanks. D things had started to come to a boil
and they become very vocal. They call themselves the Women's Liberation Movement
section. Race because they are easy.
Visible differences have been the primary ways of organizing human beings into
superior and inferior groups,
so in the late sixties and early seventies people like glorious dynamo.
We are talking about a society in which there will be no roles other than those
chosen
free from the diseases of racism. Adrienne Boyd,
I've sexism, a process.
They get some traction saying, okay, it's time to put us in the constitution.
Hurry up. I'm a historian. Say It's a constitutional convention for women.
The adoption of the following resolution
you see is this push for something called the equal rights amendment.
The equal rights amendment should be rabbi
[inaudible].
It will be ratified. This ratified early next year. I was quite sure.
I bet in 1975 that will be ratified, but it didn't get the votes.
In 1975 I hope 1976 will be the year or in 1976 a special report on the 1977
national women's conference or in 1977 and the movement is stalled.
Why? What? What stalled it? Well, a lot,
but much of the credit goes to this
one man in Phyllis Schlafly of Allen, Illinois,
a woman
named Phyllis Schlafly
two was sick. My husband Fred, for letting me come today.
I love to say that because it irritates the women's livers more than anything
that I said.
She was a lawyer and a self-described housewife who started a movement called
stop era.
The whole thing is misrepresented as a woman's rights amendment. In fact,
the principle beneficiary will be men.
It will give men a great opportunity to get out from under their obligations.
Her position was that the equal rights amendment would actually strip women of
this special privilege that they have that comes from being a woman?
Probably not.
I think though the laws of our country have given a very wonderful status to the
married woman and the wife has a great deal of many rights. For example,
she has the legal right to be supported by her husband
and she said if this amendment passes,
there will be certain unintended consequences.
The equal rights amendment says you cannot discriminate on account of sex and if
you want to deny a marriage license to a man and a man or deny a homosexual the
right to teach in the schools or to adopt children,
it is on account of sex that you would deny it and that would be
unconstitutional under era.
And that argument caught on.
I would caution the members of this platform committee that they are things that
could happen from the passage of an era amendment that none of us would like to
see happen.
Um, I think that families would generation after generation deteriorate.
I think that there would be homosexual to expect preferential treatment.
If you said, brother, we're all in danger.
You got to hear what I have to say because you know what's going to happen if
they pass the Er. There will be women in all of our bathrooms,
women using all our stalls. They'll be wasting the paper towels.
They'll be hung out in the yard or in the halls.
They'll be pushing the old soap scorners pushing the hot air dryers to the past.
The Yardi Lord, I don't know what they're going to do.
[inaudible]
had the equal rights amendment passed legal editor, Linda Hirshman. Again,
it would've looked a lot like the racial civil rights movement did,
but the equal rights amendment did not pass.
It fell three states short to get a constitutional amendment passed.
Turns out you need three quarters of state legislatures to say they want it.
That is 38 out of 50 they only ever got 35
do. So the question is,
if you want to get equal rights for women written into the law,
what do you do? There's no era. The women's lived movements sparked
backlash. Like what do you do?
Well,
enter stage left.
Not, not
RBG. [inaudible]
Ruth Bader Ginsburg,
RBG can do 20 pushups and not the so-called girl kind. Yeah.
Before she was a supreme court justice feminist icon or a workout sensation.
All the, before all that, Ruth Ginsburg,
she was at the ACL. Ooh,
this was in the 70s and one of the characteristics of Ruth Ginsburg,
which exists to this day
very well, you can hear this.
It's the first time she argued in front of the Supreme Court in 1973 when you'd
ask her a question, there would be silence
enough silence
to make a person nervous and start trying to help her answer the question.
You had to wait, but
we can imagine that it was in one of those long pauses at Ruth Bader Ginsburg
rescued some of the key principles behind the era,
repackaged them and marched them in through a side
door.
Mr Chief Justice and may it please the court sex like race is a visible
characteristic, daring known,
necessary relationship to ability sex like race has been the,
made the basis for unjustified
[inaudible].
Wait, so backing up a second, what, what exactly did RBG do?
So let me walk you through it now cause it's, it's beautiful. Um,
the era fight is underway and RBG and her colleagues are watching this happen,
right? And they're getting worried. What if the era doesn't pass?
So what are we gonna do if that's the case,
how are we going to get equal rights for women? So they decided, okay,
as an alternate approach, let's go back to the 14th amendment,
the 14th amendment,
immediate objective wash to provide national protection for the newly freed
slaves. You know, which as we said,
was designed from the beginning to be only about race,
but it sweeping provisions suggest broader objectives.
The states were prevented from depriving any person equal protection of the
laws. Well it says the word person.
So that should include women. Yeah.
If they could just get the courts to see it that way,
then by default almost we would have a sort of era.
And accordingly,
the task was showing that the racially inflected 14th amendment applied to sex.
The what about the law? Is she trying to change what,
what does she want the court to say?
She wants the court to say that sex would be treated just like race.
And here's why.
That's so when the court sees racial discrimination happening under the 14th
amendment, it takes a really hard line. It looks at it really,
really closely or at least it's supposed to.
Whereas other kinds of discrimination,
not so much because actually some discrimination is necessary.
The law discriminates. It has to,
it discriminates between 18 year olds and 17 year olds between criminals and non
criminals. There would be chaos otherwise. Right.
But the courts decided that race is going to be a big red flag.
They're going to ask the governments, legislatures,
presidents to have a compelling reason and compelling state interest to do race
discrimination. Otherwise it's going to be unconstitutional. You with me so far?
Yes. To discriminate based on race.
You need to pass a really super hard test by the way.
The legal name for this test. Oh, strict scrutiny. Oh,
I know.
They should have called it like what do you mean business or something like
that. But anyway, the point was that like they took it seriously,
which you know,
back in the day they weren't doing with sex discrimination at all because when
legislators would come up with these laws like this women can't be bartenders
law, the Supreme Court would be like, you know,
hey guys probably have a good reason for that.
It doesn't have to be [inaudible]. It can just be a reason.
Doesn't have to be very good. This up to be good.
They could even maybe even make it up on the fly.
It just has to be a reason for upholding this law.
Like in the case of the bartenders, law bars are dangerous.
Women need more protection. And of course it would be like, okay, sure.
So RBG needed a way to convince the court to be as intense about sex
discrimination as they were about race discrimination.
But how do you convince an audience of men,
aw,
we're used to discriminating on the basis of sex who've been doing it for years?
How do you convince them that discrimination is a bad,
I think of people who want to keep women down with like nothing better than to
women go off in a corner and speak only to women. Nothing would happen.
This is her giving a recent talk about her 1970 strategy.
You need to persuade men that this is ripe with society.
Part one of her strategy. Choose your words carefully.
I had a secretary at Columbia who said,
I'm typing these things for you and jumping out all over the pages.
Take seconds.
Okay.
To know that the audience you are addressing that the first association of those
men with the word sex is not what you're talking.
Okay? So why note
you use the grammar book term use gender because you know what the word sex has
a charge to it.
Gender is cooler and part two of her strategy.
Choose your cases carefully.
This is all happening in the 70s when RBG is the head of the ACLU women's rights
project.
So she's deciding which kinds of cases the HCLU is going to support as they make
their way to an all male supreme court. And her strategy was,
if we live in a man's world right now,
we need to find cases that nine men at this moment can handle.
So, for example, early on in her tenure at the women's rights project,
the other lefty lawyers are suggesting that the women's movement needs to take
up the cause of lesbian rights. And she says,
not yet.
And I think go slow is
the right approach. She said,
first we need to go after that small and insidious idea at the supreme court had
been keeping alive for years.
So the laws of our country have given a very wonderful status to the married
woman. And that, yeah,
Phyllis Schlafly idea that discrimination is actually good for women.
Gender classifications will always rationalized as favors to women.
And so RBG decided not just to bring cases where women were the victims of
discrimination. Okay. Uh, my name is Curtis Craig.
She brought cases where men were the victims.
Who were you as an 18 year old?
No, that's a great question. Um,
that was like any 18 year old young man, um,
invincible. You know, thought I was quite the ladies man.
Hm.
You name it. I mean,
he made it into Lambda Chi Alpha at Oklahoma state and he was
living
frat house. Our, uh, our fraternity was primarily made up of wrestlers.
So it was, uh, when you went down the hall,
you were about to be taken down at any moment.
You'd be thrown into the wall and you'd, you'd leave a body print.
What do you mean, like an indentation? Literally in the wall or like, yeah,
it was, it was amazing. There was a lot of partying going on. Yeah.
[inaudible] it'd
be the yard would be filled with beer cans. And here's the key.
If they wanted to get all that beer, we bang my glasses down.
They had to enlist the help of the ladies. Yeah. I mean, uh,
you know the sorority sisters, yes.
You would have a female buy your beer and you'd go out and party.
They need the women to buy beer. Yup. Why?
Because in Oklahoma state at the time, oh,
Brahma had a very silly lot.
Girls could buy beer at age 18,
but the boys had to wait until 21.
And there was something about the level of maturity, I guess,
for women versus men at that time.
The basic principle was that boys got into more car accidents,
so they should be trusted with less beer.
Did that make you angry? Oh, absolutely. Well, it was extremely unfair. Yeah.
I would say it made, I think most men angry.
Yeah.
At the time I'm a supreme court case was born.
So the thirsty boys at a fraternity, uh,
brought this case.
So the RBG RBG gets involved in this beer case. Yes. But this is a,
this is a, this is a situation where women have rights. Men Don't have,
why would she want to argue this case? I would imagine she'd want the opposite.
Well, this is where her strategy is kind of like, okay,
Trojan horse. If you look at this case right on the outside,
it looks like a case about men being discriminated against. Yeah.
But if you think about it,
beneath that discrimination is actually this kind of unspoken idea about women.
So go with me on this, right? If men are irresponsible,
they can't handle beer, then women, girls are more responsible.
And well-behaved, more delicate,
but they can be trusted with something like beer cause they won't abuse it,
you know? So with that line of thinking,
it's not long before you're trying to protect women, protect them from,
you know,
scary places like bars or courtrooms or political office.
Using this case,
RBG is able to walk into the court this discrimination about men,
but also the discrimination against women that's attached to it or inside of it.
Oh that's clever. Yeah, we're just getting started.
[inaudible] [inaudible] more perfect continues intimate
stuff.
More perfect is supported by ZipRecruiter. 2018 has begun.
And if you're setting new goals for your business, you need the right talent.
That's where ZipRecruiter comes in with one click zip recruiter post your job to
over 100 job boards.
Then they find the most qualified candidates and invite them to apply.
No wonder 80% of employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day.
Zip Recruiter at the smartest way to hire to try ZipRecruiter for free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/more perfect.
That's ziprecruiter.com/more perfect.
In the s mass incarceration starts young.
I'm having dreams and what happened in the dreams.
They put in those tight handcuffs on me and bring me set of back room,
locked me in the south. How often do you have these thoughts? A daily cut.
I'm Kai, right?
The host of caught a new podcast about juvenile justice from w NYC studios for
the past year.
We've been following kids as they ping pong through the criminal justice system
to hear their stories, listen and subscribe to [inaudible]
caught wherever you get your podcasts.
This is my perfect MGI boom rod here with Julia Longoria,
who's telling us the story of a case involving boys in beer that became a kind
of Trojan Horse
[inaudible]
in the battle for women's rights.
now the story of the Trojan horse, maybe you know this, it's uh,
you know ancient Greece. You've got Sparta fighting.
Troy's Spartans want to get into the city of Troy,
but it's this giant walled city too big they can't get in.
And so Odysseus comes up with this clever plan.
We'll give the Trojans this giant wooden horse.
They'll bring it into their city.
They'll think it's a gift that we're retreating, which is what they thought.
And then at night, our soldiers who were hidden inside the horse will
[inaudible]
and they will take the city. Now in our case, Odysseus is,
is RBG the city she's trying to get into as the all male supreme court.
But in order for this very admittedly imperfect analogy to work,
um, we need someone in the horse to come out the warrior in the horse,
the woman warrior.
And in our case, that woman warrior,
she didn't even know she was going to go into battle.
No,
Julia, you take it from here.
So I got in the car and I drove a long time,
tiny little gravel road leading up to narrow street of houses to Sparta,
North Carolina. Oh, it's called Sparta.
I know the cows and horses and Trump science
tractor up front, trespassing.
And so I walk up to this house,
it's this beautiful cream colored cottage perched on top of a mountain.
Wow.
And I can hear Whitney Houston's saving all my love for you.
Blasting you travel. Hi. No, I didn't you Carolyn.
Hi. Very nice to meet you. And I meet Carolyn Whitener.
I'm 76 soon to be 77 she be here
immediately offers me a course. Yeah.
Oh, you have a beer with me? No I can't. I'm a diabetic.
I can drink a little bit. Not Match. Thank you.
And I've got some brownies over here. What does she look like?
Describe her reddish blonde hair. Green eyes, spring golden hoops.
She has like this here,
this air about her that she could have been a beauty queen, you know,
but she also could have been a car mechanic. Match yourself.
So we get to talking. I tell her a little bit about who I am, about the story.
She actually told me like a friend, she's like, I'm proud,
I'm proud of the young women. I have a granddaughter there. I'm so proud of you,
your generation. They're finishing the fight.
I started and I was essentially like, no, no, no, no.
This stuff like your story has like a huge impact on like women like me,
you know, generation.
But see my name was never tied in with it. It was always Craig's name.
So you know, it wasn't that big a deal.
She told me she grew up bouncing around different oil fields.
I was on a little field trash, that's what we were called or field trash.
That meant Carolyn and her brother and sisters split the school year between two
or three schools a year. We moved a lot.
She said school didn't come easily to her, but my dad,
he taught all three of us how to weld. He was a welder, how to work on a car.
She was very independent and when she was about 13 they moved to Chickasha.
Oklahoma
happened there? No, low home, Huh?
Is where she met Dwayne. That was the first boy I went with.
They met in high school and they were roughly the same age,
but he was three years ahead of her at school and no. What attracted you to him?
His mind.
He had an excellent mind and he was just a farm boy with no education.
He never went to college that he could have been about anything he would have
wanted to have been. What do you think attracted him to you? Like,
what do you think he saw in you? I was somebody new in town talking to Carolyn.
I got the sense she did not have any shortage of suitors that not married him
please.
And when I married my husband, uh,
I was equal to him except the money and he didn't think anybody could handle
that, but him, he acted like he was raising me and he probably was,
she says she was really comfortable with him.
He was a quiet man with this brilliant mind,
but he just was, he was pure German girl.
Have you ever met a German man? Okay.
They are in total control. And how does Carolyn, uh,
connect to the case with the Frat boys and RBG? Okay, so here's what happens.
It's 1962.
Carolyn and Duane are about 20 years old at this point and they moved to a town
called Stillwater, Oklahoma to open a business and
do water
is a college town.
It's that college town that you got Oklahoma State University right there.
Tons of fraternities, including lambda with the wrestlers.
Huge homecoming drawing,
40,000 alumni. We didn't know what homecoming was,
had no idea what homecoming was. But shortly after moving just the water,
they opened the doors to the honk and Holler
and where we went in was just about three blocks,
four blocks from the college, and we went into business there,
a drive through convenience store.
It was like the real old gas station with the opiate in the floor.
Here's how it would work.
Customers pull up to the side of the convenience store and they drive through,
honk their horn, holler their order,
and you'd have to go out and wait on them,
come back in and get what they wanted and take it back out.
So it's a lot of in and out, in and out
all night long. You wear tennis shoes out real fast.
So it was all sheer energy and guts. Homecoming night,
we were supposed to close it for 11 the store is flooded with customers till I
think two or three o'clock in the morning.
They were like thrilled because they've never run a business by themselves
before and all these college kids are coming in and buying quarter's beer,
including of course a steady stream of girls buying beer presumably for their
boyfriends and it a, yeah, I never did get to see homecoming.
All I saw was cars coming in and out. Fast forward a few years,
it's 1972 back at the university. He's a tall,
had long blonde hair. Curtis Craig's buddy named Mark Walker,
he was the president of Lambda Chi House at the time is in a political science
class and the professor starts talking about the whole fight for the [inaudible]
Dra, which is happening right at that moment.
And at this point Oklahoma hasn't ratified the era and somehow the conversation
turns
this beer law, Mark's like talk about discrimination.
This beer law is discrimination against us.
And the professor challenged him about doing something about the bear laws if he
was going to complain about him.
So one day I was behind the counter people coming in and out.
Mark Walker walks into the honk and holler. The young man came in to talk to me.
She doesn't really have time to talk. She's running in and out,
but he stood there waiting patiently.
I bet he was in there for hours and he was looking at the beer license.
He looks at the license and he notices that Carolyn's name is the one on it
because actually my husband lost his license after he sold beer to a young man.
So he put him in my name. Anyway,
at a certain point in between all the honks and Hollers,
he asked me what I thought about the beer laws and I told him I was very vocal
about it. I always had band. She says, it doesn't make any sense.
We send these young men off to war,
were being drafted at 18 oh we don't let them drink beer when they come back.
Was that just at the mention the liability issues.
You have these 18 year old girls coming in buying beer,
slipping into their boyfriends. How am I supposed to stop that? You're,
you can't prove who buys what.
So eventually when Mark Walker asked for her help,
he said he was going to do a term paper. She's like, sure, why not?
I was always willing to help them because they had helped us get started and I
still thought it was a term paper.
So was he not being completely honest with you then? Well,
I didn't hear half of what he said. I was busy every time he came in.
So, you know, it wasn't that important at the time.
So I didn't think any more about it. He left, my husband was gone.
He was out of state working.
And I didn't even say anything to him about it. It wasn't important, you know,
I just thought it was a conversation,
but it wasn't just a conversation because before that meeting,
mark had gone out looking for a lawyer. That's correct.
And Curtis and mark and the other frat brothers had tried to raise some money
that was flawed. Um, in a campus town,
everybody uses their last dollar for that last bear.
They managed to find this lawyer who would do it on the cheap. All right,
well I'm just Fred Johor. The attorney at law, no big thing. Mono. No big deal.
I remember him always wearing 'em, his military boots. Actually,
I believe he wore them even to the supreme court.
Fred had worked on another male discrimination case in the past and to him this
case was pretty straight forward.
Man couldn't buy beer until they are 21 but most irresponsible and drunken woman
in the state could buy a limited quantities that 18 well,
that was discrimination. It was kind of more a male rights case.
Well, it was. Do you remember corresponding with Ruth Ruth Bader Ginsburg? Yes,
I knew Ruth Bader Ginsburg before she was on the court.
Somehow Ruth Bader Ginsburg noticed this case and she watched as Fred made his
way up the courts losing at every level and by this point,
Ruth Bader Ginsburg was head of the women's rights project at the ACL view.
She'd already argued a few cases before the Supreme Court,
which had inched the court slowly toward the idea that sex was like race,
and she thought that this case was interesting. She gave Fred a call,
you know we have a problem in a personal relationship, there's no question.
I was
something of an unreconstructed male chauvinist and she was not,
Fred did not see this as a women's rights case,
which just kind of an unnecessary insult. Demand for no reason at all.
And Ruth looking at this case. Dot. No, Fred, it's more than that.
It didn't matter to her if the plaintiff was a man or a woman because in most of
those cases the discrimination against the man was derivative of a prior and
worst discrimination against [inaudible].
The woman
used to the lady is the fair and the weak. How do they do?
Where do they find all that energy,
that seemingly inexhaustible store of pep and ginger.
Again,
Ruth was after the stereotype about women that was nestled inside the beer law,
that women are more responsible and well behaved,
but in order for her to make that connection,
she needed Fred to write his brief in a way that would be useful to her.
So refer not just to male discrimination,
but discrimination based on gender. Well,
I supported her. I just never was shall we say,
a militant feminist. So like Ruth had her work cut out for her at this point.
She was getting sort of used to dealing with these robes from the sticks.
So with other local lawyers that she'd worked with in the past,
Ruth had been more forceful insisting that she make the argument,
but that had backfired. So she liked, it's like, okay, you argue it. Right.
Cause she wrote that Fred telling him that she didn't need to be the one to
present oral argument before the court. She was fine if he'd do it,
but she very gently,
very persistently was able to convince him to let her help him with his legal
brief and bet. I think it was a,
a couple of months later, because my husband was out of state every month.
Meanwhile back at the Hong Kong Holler, Carolyn has no idea what's going on. Uh,
no, uh, no idea. And I got a phone call.
My husband was on the phone.
Well I had salesman in and I had people coming in and out and he was,
I right, he was furious.
I couldn't figure out what was going on. She was like, case,
what are you talking about? Well,
he had picked up a newspaper in North Carolina and a bank and it was on the
front page of the newspaper with my name and about as soon it looked like we
sued everybody in the state of Oklahoma that was in office all the way down to
the garbage man. He's like, what did you do? How are you,
we don't want to get mixed up in this. We don't want our name on this.
We don't want to make a fuss like this could hurt business. Like, how dare you?
You know? I didn't know what had happened. I really didn't know.
And eventually she figured out it must've been that kid who came in here and now
it's like at the Supreme Court, what?
I was back and forth on that phone with him trying to wait on customers and I
bet that took about three hours and he would not let up on me.
And he kept calling back and call him back. He called a lawyer,
he was mad and then the last phone call he said,
I am flying back in. And he said,
you picked me up a couple nights later she drove to the airport,
picked him up and uh, he was still mad.
That was the longest car ride.
As they drove back, she says he just lectured her the whole ride.
I just listened to him. What did he say?
I don't know what he said word to word.
I just know he was strong with what he said
with my husband, it was best to just be silent.
I was never afraid of him, but I knew how far to push it.
Tell Him we got from the airport to the other side.
It was about an hour and 20 minutes.
That's a long hour and 20 minutes in the car where you can't get out.
And over the course of that hour and 20 minutes,
she said something in her just kind of shifted and at a certain point she
basically turned to him and was like, no,
like, I know you want me to drop this case but I'm going to fight this.
He threatened me every which way.
I didn't budge and probably the reason why I didn't budge because he fought me
so hard on it. You know,
I believed in it that I hadn't ever stepped out like that.
That's the first time I really put my foot down and didn't budge.
I gave so much to him. I mean,
I didn't get a salary for 25 years. I didn't ask for it.
I figured we were equal.
I figured I worked the same hours he did and I figured I stood beside him,
not behind him and not in front of him.
October 5th, 1976 the day of oral arguments, the lawyer,
Fred Gilbert, I haven't ran across very many people that I didn't care for him.
I didn't care for Fred. He, he was so pushy.
Insists that Caroline needs to come to d c or I didn't have the money to go when
I didn't want to go and never traveled anywhere by myself.
What I recall that day Curtis Craig came to, I was dressed up,
suit and tie, had borrowed a dress, plastic look like leather,
walking up those stairs, high heels. I remember that distinctly.
It was so big, beautiful building.
I felt like I was walking forever up those stairs. I was burning up,
I was sweating.
You don't hear arguments neck 75, six 28
Craig Against Foreign Gilbert, you [inaudible] whenever you're ready.
Fred Gilbert starts things off.
He walks up to the podium in his combat boots.
The law is broad and all conversing and it's sweet.
It says they're all females. Even those that are the most drunk, most alcoholic,
most immature and most irresponsible may purchase 3.2% beer at age 18 and
absolutely unlimited quantity. The law doesn't say it quite those words does it
by all accounts. He didn't exactly kill it.
No, your honor. And the law doesn't say it quite the words that, uh, all males,
the justice is just kept hammering.
I mean, your honor, the van door's still, he can get the leaf at the movies,
age back and dread hammering in a technical sense.
I don't technical once you're on it, but it might as technical, yes.
Complaint is drafted and what does before the court will put you, say you say,
what's before the court? What's before the court is your complaint?
Curtis was sitting beside me and I kept punching him. What does that mean?
What are they talking about? What does that mean? He kept saying, Shh,
just be quiet too. This over. I'll tell you,
you're already doing [inaudible] movies, any of the tracks right then door,
who is trying to sell them?
I didn't understand what they were doing.
Fear Law that we challenged today was originally inactivity 18 nights,
but she says what caught her ear was a moment when justice Rehnquist when he
call me.
When you say we, you're referring to your client who is the tavern keeper?
The saloon.
Yes, your honor.
I'll tell you when, when you call me that and the Supreme Court, I came so near,
standing up incorrect and him and I always wondered to this day, why?
Well, isn't the DFT technically turned right?
As arguments went on,
Fred did at least try to do the thing that Ruth wanted him to do.
Your honor, I would say anything could be,
you could pass a law saying no negro will drive while intoxicated,
compare sex discrimination to race discrimination.
Now this relates to the public thing, but you,
the thing is you can't discriminate even for something like public safety on the
basis of certain criteria. Well,
has the court ever held that discrimination of this sort is of the same class?
Is discrimination the basis of race? Your honor, this court has come very,
very well. I asked you a question. Has It ever held? No. It has never held,
but it is totally to be treated the same as restaurant.
To make a long story short, by the end of oral argument,
things were looking great for Fred.
See, I mean, I think that depends on the thrust of ours. All right,
let me explain this. First of all,
we did at one point, [inaudible] interrupts a supreme court justice,
which verge, this all. You don't do that
hoarding the denial of beer to young men. 18 to
it. Just uh, yeah. I wasn't happy.
No, I don't have time for a parting thought. I thank you for your time.
Thank you, Jonathan. The case is submitted.
Well, you win some, you lose some, right ladies. No, no, no, no, no.
Here comes the craziest part of the story.
It's like a double Trojan horse horse within a horse because after the Fred
Gilbert debacle, there was another case at the Supreme Court that afternoon
and it just so happened
that it was a case being argued
by none other than Ruth Bader Ginsburg. Somehow she organized.
I've now forgotten how to get that argued the same day. That was on purpose.
Yeah. Oh yeah. Oh my God. That's genius. Yeah. No, she's a genius.
Mr Chief Justice and may it please the court what you're saying.
She somehow managed to get herself in the court on another case on the same day,
so I couldn't confirm that for sure. I don't even know how you would do that,
but what I can tell you is that she arranged to go second because she knew there
was probably a good chance that Fred,
the completely incompetent lawyer was going to be, you know,
less than amazing. The court was,
was asking him questions and he was completely incapable of answering.
So finally the court just went, oh, nevermind.
And then when Ruth's do an octa argue her case,
they asked her about Greg Vibhor.
You had a case this morning just to be concrete involving a law that would not
permit males to make certain purchases if females get make and was attacked as
it discrimination against males.
My question is whether we should examine that law under the same or a different
standard than if it were a discrimination against.
The question is no,
in part because such a law has an insidious impact against females.
And then she told Justice Stephens,
even in this case where it seems like men are the ones who are being
discriminated against. Beneath that discrimination is a more insidious one
against females. It stabs them docile compliance, safe to be cleared.
Your answer always depends on their finding some discrimination against females.
Is it your view that there is no discrimination against males?
I think there is discrimination against male.
If there is such discrimination is it to be tested by the same or by a different
standard from discrimination against females.
My response to that Ms. Justice Stevens is that almost every discrimination that
operates against males operates against females as well.
Is that a yes or a no answer? I just don't understand you and I,
I you're trying to avoid the question and now I am not trying to avoid the
question.
I'm trying to clarify the position that I don't know of any line that doesn't,
that doesn't work as a two edged sword.
It go back and forth a bit.
Justice Stevens is basically like why do you keep insisting on this?
Like why do you keep saying that discrimination against men contains within it
discrimination against women. They're different and she's like, no,
they're not different.
So your case depends in an are enlightening this case as a discrimination
against female.
My case depends on your recognition that using gender as a classification
resorting to that classification is highly questionable and should be closely
reviewed.
She makes this point again and again,
all discrimination based on gender is bad and it should be checked with
something at least approaching that hardcore standard that the court uses for
race. That was really something seeing this little woman.
Yeah. I don't know of any purely anti male discrimination.
I'll never forget that because she was small.
In the end. The women are the ones who end up hurting. Yes,
she's so small and person,
but she had a lot of force going hurt cases.
About two months later,
judgment,
December 20th, 1976
Craig against a Marham
Justice William Brennan announces that the court
we reversed.
It's striking down the beer law.
We hold that Oklahoma's gender based differential does constitute and Nvidia's
violation of the equal protection clause.
This silly beer case was basically the first time the court clearly said that
when you discriminate based on gender,
you need to pass a harder test.
It wasn't as rigorous as race. It wasn't strict scrutiny.
They settled on a standard that we now call intermediate scrutiny and it was
pretty damn close.
RVG would go on to strengthen the standard over time. But this was the case
that first got us a kind of equal rights amendment through a side door.
We wish that the court had picked a less frothy case to make that announcement,
but of course we look very,
very pleased that after that the day the decision was announced,
I had just came in from work. I was at home by myself there in Stillwater.
She's by herself in the kitchen and the phone rings and who calls who called
national news call to tell me that we had won.
I didn't ask what we had one,
I didn't ask anything. I just said okay.
She hung up,
stood there for a little bit and then Craig called and he wanted me to come down
and celebrate with the guys there or his fraternity. Fraternity. Yeah.
She told him no thanks.
And then she hangs up the phone and she gets one more phone call and it was my
husband,
he was in North Carolina again and he heard he heard something about the case
but he didn't hear it all. And he said, what's going on now? And I said,
uh, we won. And he says, is it over? I said, it is over,
it's totally over with. He said, good. And he hung up.
I fixed me a very good drink.
Vodka and coke sat down in the middle of the floor and that's the way I
celebrated. I drank that,
drank all by myself and it was over with. It was over with
[inaudible].
Carolyn says that for decades after this case,
she didn't understand what it meant.
She didn't understand what it meant as a legal principle or that it ushered in
this new era for women in this country.
But even so in
her own life,
this case was the beginning.
Wait a couple of years after we won that case and went into China right after it
opened up, she saved up money and went with her sister-in-law.
Cause Dwayne didn't want to come with him. I did.
I was so curious and we never went like the tourist went,
we'd get on a train and if we saw something we wanted to stop and see,
we would stop. We never had a schedule
and I never did really go to shop.
I was just curious about the people and how they lived.
I saw so much and I talked to so many people,
I was gone that uh, it was like a hunger
[inaudible]
and you grow from it. Yeah.
And I just wanted to see things and that was just dope.
That just opened the doors for me.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
what happened to Carolyn in the end? She and Duane divorced in 2007.
Huh. And, and when you,
and when you said she didn't know the effect her case had for decades,
like when did she figure it out or when did what,
how so in around 1996 this professor guy named Bob Darcy calls her up and
invites her to speak at a class and she is kind of learning from the students
and from the professor like what the case actually stood for.
And then eventually the professor puts her in touch with Ruth Bader Ginsburg and
they meet again in person and it sort of starts to Donna,
one of the letters,
I don't know if that's a one when we're sitting in her bedroom,
she was looking through some old letters and pulled out one with the supreme
court seal on it. Can you read it? Oh No, I don't have my glasses.
You have to read. Okay dear Carolyn,
as I told you in 1996 when we celebrated the 20th anniversary of Craig vs borne,
you are the true heroine of that case.
Although no financial gain was at stake for you.
You realize the potential the case had in paving the way for the courts
recognition of equal citizenship,
stature of men and women as constitutional principle.
Yeah,
I bet I was going to get that framed. I haven't done it yet. Hm.
Signed Ruth Bader Ginsburg. I need to get it laminated for I have your friend,
ah,
producer Julio Longoria. Um,
I've and Rod, thank you for listening and here is more perfect in radio labs.
David Gable to read the credits.
Supreme Court audio is from OEA,
a free law project in collaboration with the legal information institute at
Cornell.
Leadership support for more perfect is provided by the Joyce Foundation.
Additional funding is provided by the Charles Evans used memorial foundation.
That's it.
I want to read more. More perfect is produced by me. Jad Eben Rod, Susie,
lectin verge, any Lawton, Julia Longoria, Kelly PIR. I'm
Sean Arama Swarm. Who's no longer here. Alex over at tendon sorrow. Cari,
I didn't even get to say it.
Okay.
Oh, anytime. I love doing this.
I used to do it. I did voiceovers when I lived in Japan because I was a native.
I used to sing at Tokyo Disney land and my side Gig on my days off,
or was recording voiceovers at a little Japanese studio.
I did a lot of language lessons for kids. Listen,
and repeat.